hello everyone how's it going and
welcome back to GameSpot live happy
Wednesday hope everyone has a has been
having a great week so far today we are
gonna be playing Ori and the will of the
wisp oh yeah sorry we're a little bit
late my xbox decided to take it sweet
old time starting up yeah it's nice to
finally have those sweet beautiful tunes
honestly if you played the first one you
know this games already very visually
stunning and beautiful and with this one
it's you know it's exactly well not
exactly the same but the same in terms
of it's very whimsical and very
beautiful the music is very relaxing and
all that jazz so let's go ahead and hop
on into it
whoo sounds like a Titanic song by
Celine Dion I know right it's pretty
pretty yet what's cool
yeah chat hello how's it going hello go
sticks for being here and Blake and
David and Brandon's back element old
zombie immediately dropped everything
that they were doing to get here so
thank you guys so much
yeah III got cancelled Wow I know right
it's pretty crazy I mean obviously I
totally understand and it's obviously
for everyone's safety but it's still
like whoa it's really crazy because it's
also like few months out yeah they were
like it's been like on the cusp like a
lot of things they're just getting a
like cancel they're dropped or people
working from home things like that
postponed yeah we'll see man I think
they're gonna try to make this online
only type of III but that's for down the
line may or may not happen
but let's toss all those worries out the
window for just a short while and let's
play some games time to clear our auras
yeah exactly
Wow let's do it brand new I'm gonna
no I'm gonna do normal okay good I
because Richie and I are gonna take
turns and Richie hasn't played before
and it's been a long time since I played
the first one
so yeah gather around chat I know
watching story time
halep says watching at work oh it's dead
there okay man I always loved the art
yeah it's like you're playing a painting
it's very beautiful
[Music]
now the first 20 minutes I'm aware of
because we put we capped it for gameplay
and put it on our GameSpot gameplay
Channel
[Music]
so you guys will get quite the
introduction here oh good night
that's just so cute okay I agree the
first Ori was really good definitely had
my heart hurtin
apparently this one's not far from that
either look what's already going on the
poor little owl dude
[Music]
everyone's smiling yeah they want to
help them all her sees me cool
and everyone else
your time has passed who was learning to
walk
[Music]
Daniel said he's gonna play this tonight
noise noise yeah ash is loving the music
it's so calming that's that's one of my
favorite things about this series now we
can say officially oh best buds like a
cat Wow looks so nice like you know it
to merely make it immersive there's like
no hood or anything just really Pleasant
music and seamless storytelling Oh
scared to fly it's okay little busted we
good first attempt though oh it is now
autumn so cute you know elemento said I
can't get this stupid smile off my face
yeah that's really I don't think I've
stopped smiling since this whole intro
started
it feels like a movie
better foods yeah a little healthier
that's a look Lori gave ah there we go
it's like a line came yeah a grub yeah
and now it's keep picking the table
whoops
[Music]
being spoiled here in the Bay Area I've
never had a snow day like that where you
can stay home from school they always
look like this in California we're going
in today that's what winter looks like
here
[Music]
wait Manoj says great graphics right so
pretty thank you for joining us today
what's the story behind this game
honestly we're gonna find out together
you're kind of looking at it right now
trying to help fly oh [ __ ]
Oh can we get a hug here where is
everyone like mashing forward okay now
you're in control great such a cool like
run psycho it's all animated very well
so smooth I didn't play the first game
[Music]
crying is the story just crying easy
like a Pixar movie where they break your
heart in the first 10 minutes every time
this looks incredible can't wait to
place as Adam thank you for joining us
hopefully yeah
Oh Daniel said they're gonna try to get
their six-year-old daughter to play this
tomorrow after school
wow man I would be so pumped as a six
year old pump now therefore COO there
for her all day all day all night not to
wake up sleeping in the past you say
we're going backwards
[Music]
it's so nice okay I almost don't want to
talk over it but hey we have this in
gameplay form if you want to see with
like no commentary on our gameplay
GameSpot Channel today we're gonna have
to chat about it we got it okay okay
there you go cool somersault like know
the flip in the air there you go oh dang
oh okay am I gonna struggle in the first
puzzle time to go help Koo
ah you even used it that's cool like
breath of the wild I kind of feel bad
that we've got a flying-type ability
when coo over here is like struggling
the fly yeah it was just sitting around
in that crate like Oh
[Music]
I like her feathers on the top of her
head if it's time to patch you up oh
that would be cute
[Music]
uber tech in the chat said I played this
game it's awesome yeah noise oh thanks
for joining us while we play
[Music]
I tried climbing that rope for 10
minutes oh yeah oh yeah that's right you
guys this game is on Xbox game past its
on xbox game pass obviously Xbox one and
then on Steam those are the no ps4 dos
which hopefully temporarily cool oh this
is awesome for you and really excited to
the mics are extra crispy we're back
[Music]
this does look like a nice game wrong
hey soos in the chat hope you get a
chance to play because this is very
pleasant so far cool there you go we'll
double jump action interesting I'm
pretty sure I could have flown up onto
that branch at the top sure oh here we
go
took over for me and I like to fly Oh No
okay
[Music]
ah
basically right I like that guy it's
like a Miyazaki character
[Music]
whoo jordan says did you get hurt from
the fire at the end of the blind forest
and that's why her wing of damage that
sounds about right
that sounds like it would meet school
acceptance honest and I'm not sure that
but ship it I like it for the book
[Music]
and the termites right
Phil acum Soarin over California and
Disney Arnett California Adventure that
ride or ease like we're kind of fart
yeah land here where we dropped in on me
[Music]
squat out
Oh
lovely just used straight up like the
music and that was here to tell their
story like we knew right away something
goes wrong yeah not a single word
Oh
we should've did a little more testing
on that uh southern right workaround
before we went into wisdom adam says
this videos is tracking my six-year-old
nephew from minecraft the power noise
will be sure to keep it a PG for you
today friend oh man rough start see
where we end up with or without a coup
No
wake up cool
they looked ready to help too it's
really getting rough out here now let's
go ory we've got a job to do
Phillip says it's like Pixar made this
game right we were talking about that
especially with the story like it
already broke our heart I don't know if
he just tuned in but there's a rough
start friends yeah I already said
oh there's the head okay cool
very minimal
[Music]
see that's thing about side-scrollers
for me is like I could have done left or
right right there huh
it's so ha normally like traditional
leads to the right but like that's
old-school way of being you know there's
no making sure oh yeah look because I'm
there something down there too nice
[Music]
we have to find [ __ ] see now I feel like
I'm going too far and I want to see
what's on the other
I see you can't go back I don't have
anymore
[Music]
okay you can down jump great not all I
guess not all platforms
I didn't be mad when I was because I saw
that green thing and I think okay good
good good
elemental zombie says there's only one
ability in particular I'm really hyped
for
[Music]
fire Oh out of me oh no I'm scared of
the light the first bad thing in this
game the first like enemy I guess he
still do that little double jumping or
was he stoned leave us alone
slug thing oh wow you even like guys so
delicately like oh there we go
I appreciated that you jumped on him
though try that out right exactly
cool oh good to know you can knock those
out
[Music]
rats it almost looked like it was right
this one will better work yeah fire any
significant differences between this and
the first game to be honest it's been a
really long time since I played the
first one
but it feels yeah I knew that was gonna
damage me
that's alright worth it
talk talk thank you know yeah it feels
the same in terms of mechanics so Cory
would make a cute plush doll you're
totally right get nervous I like to talk
[Music]
retrieve the missing key stone from the
key that was the map looks like the more
you explore the more it'll like you know
open up you like ninja gaiden jump off
that wall on the right so we're gonna
climb me that's cool oh now he's like
I'm sorry no it's gone
cry me a river eat slugs Malfoy I wonder
if I should've underneath
I don't think there's any wrong answer
we got to find two of those keys to get
past that door says tock and what is
this thing
I thought you could like swing high but
we could drive that torch I'm not sure
if that was ball damage or if you hit
the spikes and had low health yeah here
we go
Oh ding bossfight
[Music]
Oh
Wow even the little encounters are so
cool to look at visually Bob Jones yeah
made that HP reference to bet that
backfires well I know her in the movie
maybe eats looks the whole movie it's
broken I was trained of wondering if I
was gonna have the torch the whole time
but okay that little grass is Klima ball
360 no-scope Park or I should say what
happens when you press the attack with
no torch meat away
[Music]
jackpot says can't wait for neo - oh man
we got it in the office it's all gonna
say bye Phillip thanks for joining us
thank you see you next time it's good to
see you again
oh yeah got one
[Music]
did he was he like I wasn't reading I
have an oven in my backpack but you need
to okay jerk what's that I know I want
it
I like how he has like steam pops like
maybe after like an ability has learned
we can like collide or something because
that's teasing for sure old-school games
our hard-earned Keystone Gavin what's up
Gavin says you guys say hi for me
hi Gavin welcome thanks for joining us
today unless I can get out this way
buggin seas swim upstream I'm gonna go
your hip popping back and forth oh that
grass above you might be climbing
SiC flip yes gaming Oh
[Music]
oh okay okay oh here oh here we go
lair slug don't need that smoke there's
the mysterious piece of wood I don't
know drift look Gavin says this game is
so cool so far we beautiful yeah
great music just so you can chill oh
yeah we like you know a little bit of
everything but this is like a nice chill
game so far haha he hooked it up good on
his word yeah
[Music]
oh yeah sign of things to come
[Music]
nicely done
chat let me know have you guys played
part one or are you gonna jump right
into part two I might just jump into
part two well you know what though
I'll have an Xbox on Xbox and students
good afternoon Enrique thank you for
joining us
sorry weird is all up in our feels right
now
you say it don't spray it bro
for your life
parkour oh my goodness
and then there you go now he has a
health bar
[Applause]
got virgin
those cat things are watching in the
background squished
[Music]
I gave up some valuable health
Oh
Oh
elemental says this will Penn zero chill
there you go
move back and forth are the green ones
your health I think you're doing
everything you can
drop down
drop or jump
while his war
did
we go
Oh jump
can I get away
honestly I was looking at his little
life bar at the top and I'm like I'm not
gonna be worried - well you got him
cyborg man back in the chat what did you
catch that boss fight cyborg man that
was dope ha
Oh a little sliver yeah
cyborg man we heard that e3 officially
better safe than sorry
it's been so many events affected lately
feel so bad for everyone
this book's correct
I mean there was kind of a dead end over
there
some hail yeah hail and our purple stuff
is not promising right there looks like
radioactive goop it's gonna help the
crystal thing what is that hmm hmm that
is someone's spine
need another key oh it even moves like a
Bob Jones says save and heal
can we Bob Jones I don't make it these
without a torch I don't know
got a little health oh no was I supposed
to bring a torch down here so
mr. Newell Gavin you're awesome thank
you for being here it says we're awesome
and thanks for doing the stream oh here
we go
branded do they announce it for the
switch I think like there were like I
think they said like later on down the
line maybe are my tripping
it would be a perfect 15 I'm singing I
would want it on my switch too
wipe up what happened I just learned
something I think
[Music]
this guy reminds me of like dude from
Pan's Labyrinth it's like oh yeah I
remember him either
he helps pan out chained it kinda yeah
[Music]
they're looking for Koo
[Music]
follow them right got visual
storytelling kick on point there is no
official switch announcement yet okay
yeah hopefully in a year or two Bob
Jones is saying that B could it would
make for a great switch game
what's with the exclusivity man is PC
and Xbox
we are not like the other shakers
well they like you as you brought up the
wolf in new shines and ancient lake
the tree remembered it knows it has
shared its memory with you right now
yeah tell that wolf to come back now
well the city no my squad
[Music]
see me to like theme cool so you have
now you have an attached no it's like a
quick we open ah it's like GTA your gun
wheel there you go
now it's on X oh that's so cool yeah
bring it up slow and you got the little
orbs where's that walk now
[Music]
we got some goodies nice
[Music]
until zombie says everybody ganks until
the lights start biting back hey were
you at wolf
I believe we weren't done oh that was so
like nicely hidden off-screen you saw
like a glimmer of it we had a like light
bleed through
oh wow wouldn't what a tree there not a
tree but like a big list there yeah
right look at all this stuff week all
the spirit shards I wonder what the end
game looks like you know just doing a
million combos million combos all these
abilities are gonna come our way Blackie
Starr says I'm gonna play this game
right yeah more advanced than the first
one now yeah it doesn't tell you much
which is fine you have to be really have
to discover ok so to the right and up so
I gotta go that's wait I think that's
where you have been see there we
couldn't get there it was dangling no
was on a like a little cliff
well it's nice to know you can always
press Start and see where it is for
later yeah
you have full health how's it feel flip
though
nice Dodge you're on someone's spine
such a tease we can't like fly or jump
anymore are like double dong okay I have
an app is a review out for Ori I think
it's on the way soon Bob Jones
[Music]
ah Thank You Evan he says the written
review is up on the website on GameSpot
calm I call him Evian
[Music]
she also says he says also this game
looks beautiful it looks approachable
but that thing was an enemy
[Music]
looks like an epic weapon because it's
like purple like that your eyes are
drawn to it mmm hope this doesn't break
this wooden that should be enough right
game name we're playing Ori and the will
of the wisps stay tuned check it out no
I was trying to see if I could grab that
thing floating like I did there woah oh
dear oh dear yes
oh sorry you got your health back and
you unlock the door there's so many
places to go Lulu yes Isis
I must absorb the lights give me I'll be
able to use good
yes now we can go back and do so much oh
is that it
oh dang it doesn't push you up higher
but it leaves you in the air longer also
important yeah well if I go down the
first jump Italy
this is by itself an engine there we go
oh no no get out of here man me gone
[Music]
now we know what the rock is for see I
knew our abilities would have a lot to
do with these weird obstacle we weren't
ready for you oh yeah but you're your
latest goal was to like go to the right
and up I forgot already who we have to
talk to Oh
Oh lock sounds like a Star Trek
character oh all right
nail then yo my Breen those things I
would have been there for another like
five minutes there you go there you go
friends it joins us
[Music]
so like a healing station and you saved
Bob Jones that was for you like it will
pose he makes I missed it Oh
oh yeah thank you all right so we've got
the double jump and the slash that's so
cool
geez devastating oh we got some laser
action moving down there those are the
keys
oh there's a lever up on that yeah look
at that hmm
they're gonna make you do like a late
start jump and then a double jump okay
[Music]
Blackie Starr says I completed the first
Ori game nice it was also pretty as well
definitely one of my favorite things
about this game just nice to look at the
entire night there you go
a iraq from earlier perfect that's the
fun part about side-scrollers like this
that are kind of all one stage yeah you
see how each part interacts or changes
later down yeah you're not necessarily
done with an area yet you're gonna cover
the laser I see yeah slug is distracted
oh and then yeah they keep pushing it
cool Oh Johnny tsunami back in the chat
and says this game looks amazing hope
you're able to play it is available now
on Steam and Xbox on game pass even
nicely done you got that uh what was it
a crystal that thing you picked up okay
okay okay yeah see that double jump was
specifically this little wall right here
is specifically designed to make my life
miserable until we had this ability okay
now we're back here good stuff
[Music]
the map real quick nice Blackie Starr
has it installed from game pass shoutout
to game pass yeah yeah that's how I got
he looks like stitch yeah that's true
hard to ignore it's the eyes on the
shape of the head the ears the whole
thing
[Music]
really think I missed no unfortunately
it's not on PlayStation yet Roshan
currently there are no plans either we
were talking about how cool would be on
the switch to but no go at the moment
maybe later
immediately yeah
[Music]
spider-man stick is it temporary not why
would it be I don't know yeah look at
that oh I could just run up the walls
now awesome dad is gonna be useful
man I'm so curious because that's a
really really good like shard to have on
in my opinion right now
and that's just like the second one of
how many is on the screen how many can
you have equip three what I'm looking at
the Evan says lilo and Orie yeah I'd
watch that element tell zombie can't get
over that it's an exclusive to well to
the Microsoft side of things I feel you
man I'm part of the PlayStation nation
myself and I cannot enjoy this at home
anyway
[Music]
oh my goodness only inventory it really
is a skill tree it's really cool-looking
that holy crap I wanted to look at yeah
my map see we're gonna hand him on going
we can play this again sometime is so
extensive but I'd love to see everything
filled out
[Music]
there you go oh yeah really can see it's
already it's already looking it's
already performing so much better is it
there was a map right yeah yeah okay I
thought it for some reason I thought it
was up here but I'm down here
what's that portal thing that was our
safe place okay
[Music]
hey go it's so pretty and lush it's a
cell still so nice to look at someone in
the chat earlier was like imagine
playing this on like a 4k o LG TV we
have a pretty nice monitor but on the
big screen this would be nuts it's buggy
on PC no way I hope that it's been
pretty smooth for Xbox we're playing on
an Xbox one s and this isn't the best
yeah it's our cursed Xbox we were
talking about that like every Call of
Duty's 3 it's like I want to play but
I'm still downloading it it's it's that
damn Xbox the music is great as well
Johnny tsunami
let me just drop off this cue stone I'll
click alrighty
we go-oh some wall climbing
he may get to that wall because he can
maybe like I don't know jump and jump
using the rock yeah I love that I'm
under estimating for you to be honest
because I was like that looks pretty far
maybe it an ability for later site no
you've got this you are capable got them
both right
oh no Adam says this is where I'm lost
hopefully you watching this we can help
you out help each other
there you go we're also just kind of
learning here though / you're killing it
bye you waited till like the GUP oh
[Laughter]
there you go
nailed it ooh more ribs - fine
[Music]
rip never straight up surrounded by
bones like the elephant graveyard in
Lion King
Ojeda mask where this first Adam I think
you can scrub backwards you can scroll
backwards on our timeline to figure out
where the first Keystone was I can't say
you know specifically because it all
looks like this so if you rewind this
livestream which you can do we got it
somewhere you know it was somewhere over
in this area
I think okay unless we're talking about
the first area we went to then I know
how that was around here yeah yeah just
rewind it be kind rewind nowadays well
know where that line comes oh yeah
like rewinding at a VHS tape for the
video store nice love doing that how I
played a lot of video games or just
Wrentham Adam for sure friend I hope I
hope you can find where we find it I
mean you'll see it in our timeline
somewhere
hey all right
but I am brave Oh Blackie Starr says I'm
playing here right now I am happy yeah
good good good
I heard the hell we're finding it to the
east and maybe a jobs one oh okay okay
okay option one I mean yeah needs to be
to your right I guess
oh I don't know yeah yeah using the map
is you
if it's a cyclists probably not that
world
[Music]
God of Dane here we go
I'm a rope small ability for this [ __ ]
what about that stick of wood over there
is that climb aboard I think it's just
that enough of an incline that he won't
stick to it all the way which is smart
all right
we will come back for this cuz we must
need something for sure more just to
make sure nice the little ledge there
[Music]
set a new bad guy it is
okay there my little jumpy batter yeah
[Music]
okay break that it just looks break a
boy I'm sorry take more damage nah I
can't I can't with that right good to
have I guess for a boss fight or
something if if you're like top tier or
you player and you know for a fact you
won't take any damage at all and heck
yeah I would put on however you guys
have seen this so far I was I don't know
I think you're doing great
yes let me absorb the light
watch this will be the ability we need
for that site mom was stood regenerate
okay that wasn't it but it's fine yeah
still use that for sure
jump on the wooden vertical part next to
the road okay there was two one was at
an angle and one was sort of like just
vertical it will get back to that later
because this is still a new area for us
right here oh no they're not gonna let
me go back there once I go oh no oh did
I jump oh no I didn't but really saw
those thorns there you go okay this is
running very smoothly I hope it's going
so smoothly on the PC but someone in
chat was saying nah yeah I feel like the
only times I've really seen it acts kind
of sluggish was like when I was opening
the menu to look at the map oh really
okay is that high oh well there you go
now from there oh definitely I just have
to double jump on the melon
yeah and play off of this
yeah thanks guys appreciate the chat
[Music]
here we go oh so many thorns hmm
well it looks like it's gonna tip I
don't like that thing Hey okay high
style oh that was for the side quest
great great great possibly noise easy
easy money helping out a friend yeah yo
Mach oh yeah mom where you at but I'm
also generous and humble use this to
repair structures interesting okay did
anything break that you can think of
some are like was that like in a mmm I'm
just trying to think what we can use
that for
but it was a sidequest I don't think
it's required to continue the story yeah
I saw one of those earlier on in the
stage but I couldn't get to it at the
time
Roshan says soothing music oh yeah yeah
I want to listen to the soundtrack
I got Spotify
that'd be a smart move if you can put it
on there Oh God
[Music]
you sent him bouncing
[Music]
what maybe needs look like wood maybe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I like the sound of the flips down
here 200 they get up on us
I think this is like three came from I
remember that
cool-looking temple thingy wow this is
where I drop down let me see
oh man I was really far back okay well
okay look West the part might not be
here okay look at how far away you got
this so cool how the chunk the Sun the
Sun changes the whole movie I know we
can use an upgrade my maps are soggy oh
no back off let's strike a deal yes I
not currently this is on Steam and Xbox
only
[Music]
if you have game pass it's available
there oh my
wait right here yeah that didn't I mean
oh we're in the board of help whole the
whole different area so it's like an ant
maze and that maze but you know what
ants do underground they make this farm
alright that looks like it goes
somewhere still we our thumb looks like
it goes down yeah there you go
okay oh there was also it on the bottom
left there was a way down to like to a
sorry a newer area oh yeah yeah okay so
got a few options mm-hmm
if you hover over those pink stones did
they tell you what they are
no forgot what they are though isn't
that the same thing that helped us fix
the structure I mean I might be able to
go grab one of them now if I go back for
it well if you want I think we should
try to maybe go down this area so yeah
it's on the way don't forget your help
[Music]
like the sound work you sick flip Hey
[Music]
we go so graceful this is one of those
things you couldn't get earlier right
[Music]
[Applause]
see ya huh says it's 3:30 a.m. here have
fun good night thanks for tuning in with
rennet oh yeah I forgot I can I have the
better ability what is it this triangle
are or why yeah it's why but I already
forgot what it does it converts my
spirit energy into health if I need it
oh that's right it's very cool I don't
think I went
[Music]
oh that's alright okay press y he's
going Blue Square to get a green square
whoa whoa whoa back up there weirdo
[Music]
which it sounded that good when I walk
around in real life
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
yes
there you go now we can looking at it
yeah okay that's whoa okay so we wanted
to go more self because the path was
down here right okay yeah yeah decisions
[Music]
like a shark slug yeah don't care for
those sentiments
Oscar asks do you think this game is
hard increasingly yeah there you go it's
a little like puzzle II and you have to
navigate the map a lot like a you know
like a Metroidvania sort of in fact the
map looks a lot like a Metroid game
there are enough enemies it's getting
the difficulty is increasing we're
playing on normal mode what end oh wow
okay something tells me I do not have
what I need you you don't think so oh
you're even farther only because there's
no area oh yeah even a few there the
only areas like that little little chunk
or something with these things floating
middle
do something is that the lip like the
most Sambi bite action says my humble
opinion I haven't seen in any indie game
as beautiful as this one in a while what
do you think green yeah it's not sure
when you tuned in but we were saying it
from the very start it's like we're
playing like a beautiful painting it's
so there's a lot of eye candy here
[Music]
Oh No now it's getting them oh wait
forgot oh wait no that's what I was
arguing okay
it'd be cool if we have this area feels
like I'm here too early maybe all right
I get it
I'm underprepared to be to be over here
so with that said is that a safe spot
this is no it's blocked off which is
massive attack fan says so while they
took the music from Shawshank Redemption
soundtrack why I love that movie is that
true
maybe influenced by that movie cuz
that's a big movie you can't just take
from that movie without getting in
trouble
although remember the beginning sounded
like the Titanic song yeah just dodged
it
oh sure stupid slug get out of here the
string section stuff is a direct take on
Shawshank Redemption I just watched it
yesterday that's the only reason I know
I keep opening the map cut see dead
center let's one of the areas we haven't
gone VI then there's probably
[Music]
I thought this was that you did and
after you met that guy I think it still
goes further up okay
[Music]
nice coat ek the game is super pretty
said he got a few hours in last night
and today cool thank you for joining us
to watch us play take less damage yes
yes 10 per se nice trying to hide it
from me oh we can't swim in this poison
water so that's hard no there we go cool
cool wow it's like this green wool extra
green like mossy woodsy area Oscar says
when this came out my brother thought it
was Mario but he's 5 any side scroller
right is that quote long huh it's like
Rafiki Tim yeah he
discussion mr.
evil bird salesman out here in the
forest ooh
okay so spawn a spirit orb that attacks
for you okay very cool pound foes with a
strong sweeping blow who'll throw a
powerful spear of light you give and
take
throw a star that returns yeah okay set
nearby enemies on fire these are all
really cool what do these guys shoot I
like it baby any projectile like the
fire one or the arrow one but do you
you've got some options here what do you
think
[Music]
hmmm trying to think what would be the
most useful I have a pretty quick normal
attack yep for close-quarters right so
maybe the century or the spirit star I'm
kind of leaning towards these two even
though a strong attack might be good too
we got some suggestions for stars stars
and kind of take the hammer oh my gosh
you guys are all over the place we put a
pole you see two of first star I was
kind of leaning towards that one I'm
thinking so next that's that's a that's
a triple vote for star actually here
spirit smash helps with the more tanky
characters and you can combo off of it
as well ooh you like the combos okay so
which one's the hammer we have the smash
is this oh yeah it does the pike a
little hammer and you can combo into it
alright alright being decision I had
cameras or stars powerful sweeping blow
or a star that returns to you
[Music]
hammer really helps alright you know
what we'll do it well lay down there
make sure to farm some more stuffs and
come back and get the other stuff next
time won't come so cheaply now we're
broke
okay no that was already like for
underdog yeah alright time to test this
baby out oh maybe that's why we have
those things that can fix structures
because it sounds like I'm gonna be
destroying Oh new rumor rumor you're
spilling tea yeah it's none of our
business
so I thought a shrine stands in ink
water Marsh near the entrance name
shrine thank you a sign of spirits dad's
cool like chop chop smash yeah Murphy no
that's sick
there you go
[Music]
test it out on that pool yes it looks
like are you so small satisfying Raj
beer yes we have the written review for
Orion will of the wisps on gamespot comm
it's there now
[Music]
music so nice oh no that's lug her to
you they were breaking them all
perfect timing elemental zombie says
time to do some bullying with the hammer
a man they were bullying us be right
[Music]
what was that Oh tea has been spilled
what's going on a bug oh yeah back away
Oh
anytime that brilliantly more bugs
there you go this is on game paths and
speed Oh see ya
one more possibly why wouldn't that
break I hate that guy it's just a little
you're gone oh that puts you right back
here at least you're ready
elementals is coconut combo breaker
abdullah there is very there should be a
video review coming soon
i believe but currently it's just the
written one
[Music]
what you could have totally or you
should have totally hit that guy oh I
was trying to get him on that would be
cool like a skewer the foreground is up
in the way thanks hit
that was kind of cool that I could float
around though riperoni and cheese
[Music]
[Music]
got this got this damn
oh that guy oh I think now it's at the
Red Rock guys looks like Sebastian dubs
in the chat yeah we need these oh yeah
ready here hey what's that up on the top
left that's so spiky be careful all
right
let me take a look it tonight yeah again
real quick man and that was with me and
taking less damage
Oh dead
[Music]
sweet
[Music]
[Music]
huh okay all right safe up here
oh I can't
Oh walk limey or wet yeah kind of charge
up and see and linking my whole box but
I couldn't do it while I was hanging
from
we go
yes excuse me what the flim-flam this
looks like an area you've been at before
or been to before but from me Wow
I find it hard to believe they brought
me all the way up here for me not to be
able to do anything
some have a big old hammering I thought
it was onto something like I can slide
down thank you
Cody says I really like that they put
the blue moss in this game
it's nice and climbing ball
[Music]
oh no oh nice oh that blue Oh that was
us the pink thing ya know that enemy who
was trying to jump at you I think though
Persian you can use that blue pad to
like jump in between those spikes I
don't know yeah you said to get up here
oh but like going the other way where
that weird thing was like Zelda yeah no
we're here again I thought you were
gonna go like go inside of it once you
finished the shrine but it's like no he
can fight him again Daniel in the chat
not a bad game he says hmm maybe that
was an area for you to fight here we go
no no it's boogers the slug Oh Oh No
and Sebastian
they're so well animated nice the hammer
very cool choice thanks Jeff
[Music]
Oh No
laughing over here
[Music]
have you been here
who spikes huh kind of everywhere
without ya under in this area
hello thank you for joining us
I got a few more minutes here I know
it's like five minutes but still if you
want to watch this whole broadcast
it'll be saved as a pod you can watch
later
or that's cool what video game does that
I swear I was like oh oh that was good
[Music]
Cody says I got the century first and I
didn't like it the hammer made a huge
difference
pro tip then glad you were here to steer
us in that direction Cody
[Music]
oh wow in a while hmm looks like you can
put three things there just break the
shrine that's where you were that's cool
that would have been cool earlier now
it's hard down there so let's see let's
see here that quest is still so far a
flag checkered flag
was that a race oh wait the flag I think
[Music]
nice
that's like Alex KITT he can do that in
shinobi world yeah Wow really is like
Alex can you hmm well there we go that
piece of wood looks clamming bull oh
that little gap okay wow they made it
really narrow there you go
you're definitely on to something
oh don't break the bridge thanks Cody
says great to see you guys on stream fun
to watch we're happy to have you here oh
so close
thanks for the pro tips also yeah Dan
yes I can begin I know I can
you might need to hold board there we go
yeah just barely they do that a lot to
you
there we go boo-ki like double jump
after that
oh yeah piece of cake
[Music]
Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
falen woods
Oh for those of you just tuning in
that's how the game started and we have
our friend who the owl she landed
somewhere on this in this area no that's
um that's a really cool
no she's really here it's so scary
compared to where you were
[Music]
she has a busted wing we fixed it but
then there is get it oh it was like a
flashback that's letting us know
that's right hand oh hey thanks holy
they hooked it up with a bridge we are
playing on the Xbox it's only on the
Xbox and PC or now it's deep
[Music]
well I think it's a good time now to go
ahead and give it a little pause Aroo
mm-hmm that is all for our time today
however I'm hooked I love it it's
adorable I can tell because when I was
like it's almost time you're like that
was me yes we're not even close to the
next subject
we had fun exploring like there's a lot
to explore here for sure a ton of fun
really really liked it if you liked the
first one then I would definitely
recommend to you know pick this one up
as well it's just as good beautiful
great music and game passage oh my heart
anywho you guys thank you so much for
tuning in happy Wednesday again and
don't forget that every weekday at 2:00
p.m. you can catch us right here playing
all types of stuff so tune back in
tomorrow we will see you then but until
next time peace peace bye